foreign
[Music]
a customer engineer at Google Cloud
welcome back to the technical series for
startups where we are creating a series
of videos for technical enablement to
help startups start build and grow their
businesses successfully and sustainably
on Google cloud in our previous video we
learned how to use bigquery to order
data analysis needs and today we will
learn about dataproc and how we can use
it to run spark and Hadoop jobs faster
today we will be covering what is
dataproc Google data progression
on-premises deployments versus dataproc
deployments
serverless Spark
we will walk you through a dataproc demo
we will also review some sample
architecture
and lastly we will learn about one of
our customers and their data proc
Journey
what is dataproc
at Google Cloud we have learned focus on
enabling customers to modernize their
open source deployments with dataproc
our manage open source data analytics
product
as we have been on this journey over the
past five years we have learned a lot
from helping customers migrate some of
the largest Hadoop deployments in the
world to Google Cloud
as spark usage has grown we have been
focused on delivering the best spark
experience on Google Cloud
they are blocked as a processing engine
gives customers a managed Cloud
experience but without having to
re-architect applications in code
it also provides deep integration with
the rest of Google Cloud making it easy
to mix open source Solutions alongside
native Google cloud services
dataproc combines the best of Open
Source in Cloud because it's a fully
managed and highly scalable service for
running Apache spark Apache flank Presto
and over 30 open source tools and
Frameworks use data proc for data Lake
modernization
ETL and secure data science at Planet
scale fully integrated with Google cloud
and at a fraction of the coast
cloud data proc version
their product is fast without using
dataproc it can take from 5 to 30
minutes to create a spark in Hadoop
clusters on premises or through
infrastructure as a service providers
it is easy you don't need an
administrator or any special software to
use data Pro because you can easily
interact with clusters and Sparkle
Hadoop jobs through the Google Cloud
console the cloud SDK or the data
progress API
it is cost effective
dataproc charges you only for what you
really use with second by second billing
and a low one minute minimum billing
period
in a nutshell fast easy to use fully
managed cloud service to run in spark in
Hadoop clusters in a simpler more cost
efficient way to make your deployments a
success
this is how a typical deployment
on-premises using sparking Hadoop looks
like as you can see this deployment has
multiple steps that require a lot of
work and effort and are not elastic are
hard to scale fast have capacity limits
and there is no separation between
storage and compute resources
on the other hand a typical data proc
deployment is much simpler and it's only
a three-step process that can easily be
performed by one person
creating the cluster takes no time
configuring it takes around 20 seconds
and your cluster is ready to be used in
90 seconds using cloud data proc and
Google Cloud tools can save you time
money and effort because adopting a
cloud-based approach can make your
overall solution simpler and easy to
manage
Cloud dataproc provides built-in support
for Hadoop manage hardware and
configuration simplify version
management and flexible job
configuration
as you can see on screen when you're
running an Apache Hadoop cluster on
premises you have many options available
in Google cloud in order to satisfy all
of your needs for example in the yellow
Square for processing streaming data if
you use Apache spark or Kafka we
recommend you use cloud data proc while
if you use Apache beam we recommend
cloud data flow
there are other three different
scenarios in this slide to help you make
an informed decision of which products
to use and when today spark developers
spend only a portion of their time
writing code and the rest of the time
goes to planning provisioning and
managing infrastructure
this stems from the fact that we'll be
in a very powerful distributed
processing framework spark is also very
complicated with lots of parameters and
not substitute at Google Cloud we are on
a mission to give developers their time
back eliminating the need to worry about
infrastructure at all
our serverless spark offering is the
industry's first Auto scaling offering
for all workloads you write the code and
submit the job we take care of
everything else from figuring out the
best default configuration to Auto
scaling and to optimizing infrastructure
usage
unlike other Solutions or you end up
paying for the infrastructure time with
serverless spark you only pay for the
job duration period
on top of providing the API to submit
your spark jobs we have integrated the
serverless spark offering with some
other leading Google Cloud products
let's take a look at some of those
Integrations spark through bigquery the
first major integration is the spark of
bigquery giving bigquery users an
integrated SQL and Spark experience
right from the bigquery console
we have integrated a pi spark editor
into the bigquery console powered by the
serverless spark backend
now your analyst and data scientists can
write and submit by sparkcode against
bigquery data all with the same
serverless Auto scaling experience as
they're used to with SQL serverless
spark 2 vertex AI for organizations
looking to use spark for data science in
machine learning we have integrated
serverless spark with vertex AI our
unified AI platform
data scientists no longer need to go
through custom Integrations to use
sparkly their notebooks through vertex
AI workbench they can connect to spark
with a single click and do interactive
development
with vertex AI spark can easily be used
together with other ml Frameworks like
tensorflow Pi torch and bigquery ml
all the Google Cloud security compliance
in IM are automatically applied across
vertex Ai and Spark
once you're ready to deploy the ml
models the knock boot can be executed as
a spark job in NATO product and
scheduled as part of AI Pipelines
all the Google Cloud security compliance
and IM are automatically applied across
vertex Ai and Spark
once you're ready to deploy the ml
models The Notebook can be executed as a
spark job in dataproc and schedule as
part of AI Pipelines
spark through dataplex
for those looking to build a unified
platform across distributed data
dataplex provides unified security and
governance intelligent data management
and integrated analytics experience
and now we are integrating serverless
spark with dataplex out of the gate
giving you the ability to run spark
across all of your data with unified
security and permissions
at the same time your analysts and data
scientists get access to TurnKey
serverless collaborative SQL and
notebook environments across all your
data this demo shows how to set up and
use Apache spark and Jupiter notebooks
on cloud data proc
first open up Cloud Shell by clicking
the button in the top right hand corner
of the cloud console
next enable the data Rock compute engine
and bigquery storage apis using these
commands
you will need to authorize Cloud shell
now we will create a Google Cloud
Storage bucket let's make sure to give
it a unique name this will be used for
the dataproc cluster
now let's create the dataproc cluster
with jupyter and component Gateway
in order to do that first let's set the
variables for the cluster making sure to
specify the bucket we created earlier
then we will run this gcloud command to
create the cluster with all the
necessary components to work with
jupyter notebooks
now we can see the output telling us
that the cluster is being created this
should take about 90 seconds once it is
ready we will be able to access the
cluster from the dataproc cloud console
UI
create an Apache notebook
once the cluster is ready we can find
the component Gateway link to the
jupyter lab web interface by clicking on
the cluster we created and go into the
web interfaces tab
our next step is to create a notebook
with a Python 3 kernel
in order to do that from the launcher
tab click on the Python 3 notebook icon
to create a notebook with a Python 3
kernel which allows you to configure the
spark session in the notebook and
include the Sparks bigquery connection
required to use the bigquery storage API
make sure to rename the notebook to
something meaningful
in my case to save us some time I
already imported a notebook with the
code we will be using
in this notebook you will use the spark
bigquery connector which is a tool for
reading and writing data between
bigquery and Spark making use of
bigquery storage API
now let's run our spark code in The
Notebook
first we will import packages and make
sure to use the proper dependencies
after that we will create a spark
session and include the spark bigquery
connector package
now let's enable Rebel eager Evo this
will output the results of data frames
in each step and it will also improve
the formatting of the output
now let's read a bigquery table into a
spark data frame
here we are creating a spark data frame
by reading in data from a public
bigquery data set the Wikipedia page
views
this makes use of the spark bigquery
connector and bigquery storage API to
load the data into the spark cluster
next we will select the required columns
and apply a filter using where which is
an alias for filter when this code is
run it triggers a spark action and the
data is read from bigquery storage at
this point
now let's Group by title
and let's also order by Page views to
see the top pages
and this is our outcome we have
successfully read bigquery public data
sets and have listed the top Wikipedia
pages in a spark data frame
let's look at the architecture of data
proc serverless or Spark
serverless spark automates the
provisioning and auto scaling of the
infrastructure
users submit sparkcode and can provide
spark properties for any customizations
each spart executor maps to an abstract
unit called Data compute unit
data compute unit represents one
dataproc bcpu plus 4 gigabytes of RAM
billing is only for the duration the job
runs
serverless spark works with both
bigquery and cloud storage
users can attach a persistent history
server to view spark logs after the job
is finished and the hive met store as
well
once the job finishes everything is
cleaned up except the logs and persisted
results
now let's talk about one of our
customers and how dataproc has allowed
them to reduce processing times while
reducing cost
power of data works with big data and
analytics Solutions using technology to
automate and accelerate the entire data
chain process for companies seeking to
significantly improve results
the company handles data storage and
deployment elements in cloud storage and
uses several Google Cloud solutions to
refine its services even further
for instance they use data prompt Bruno
hardim the CTO of power of data told us
that the main benefit came from using
the air problem which helped power of
data reduce processing Times by 94
percent
one of their customers a retailer whose
processing time was 17 hours is now just
30 minutes this is a significant
difference that translates into time and
cost savings
in this session we'll learn more about
Google cloud data proc and how it's
integrated with other open source Tools
in Google Cloud Solutions
in the demo we learn how to use Apache
spark and Jupiter notebooks on cloud
dataproc we also reviewed the dataproc
server list for spark architecture and
we learn how power of data is using
cloud data proc
if you want to find out more click the
links in the description where you'll be
able to
read more about cloud data proc try out
the Hands-On step-by-step guides use a
ready-to-use templates
reach out and get connected today's
video focus on Google Cloud's fully
managed service for running Apache spark
in Apache head of clusters
we explore what it is how it works and
how it compares to on-premises
deployments
in the demo we show you how to quickly
set up and use Apache spark in Jupiter
notebooks on cloud dataproc
please refer to the links in the
description box to get additional
resources
be on the lookout for our next video
where we will explore what dataflow can
bring to your business how to start
using it how to design scale and
optimize with data flow and you will
also learn how to build stream data
pipelines in dataflow
and that's a wrap
don't forget to like And subscribe to
our YouTube channel click on the Bell
icon to get notified each time a new
video is posted
stay tuned and we will see you very soon
in the next video
[Music]